[Music]
i would love to hear you describe an
experience that came up in my reading it
relates to a day you found yourself
walking across a football field oh yeah
i don't know if that's enough of a queue
yeah yeah but i would love to hear you
expand on this because i did read about
it but i i feel like there's probably
more to the story so could you please
just provide
sure some color and tell the story
writers make stuff up tim
you you ask them questions that
essentially have no answers but they
make stuff up anyway so i'll tell you
what i made up yes please but it's kind
of true
sounds like my life
yeah right it's like that
mostly kind of true yeah sort of true
your previous question what did growing
up in the woods have to do with being a
writer there wasn't anything to do
except
yeah when it was raining except
reading writing and and drawing
so there were no other
things to do like no theaters no schools
no television no
what else can you think of none of those
things
so therefore i fixated on writing pretty
early
and
it was a narrative family people told
stories
and my older brother was a gung-ho
writer he wrote lots of things at that
age he he turned into a scientist but
he was very narrative
when he was a
10
9.
anyway back to the football field there
i am
uh having written my first novel at the
age of seven it was about an ant
some
structural difficulties there tim
because ants don't do anything until
they're in the fourth stage of their
life so
they don't do anything when they're an
egg they don't do anything when they're
a larva they do nothing when they're a
pupa and it's only when you get to you
know the last part of the story that
they actually have any legs
so i don't start books that way anymore
tim but i did then so then i stopped
writing i i
took to drawing i
drew a lot
and
then i ended up in high school
at slightly too early in age
uh they skipped people then
i think they've stopped doing that so i
was 12 and some of the people in my
class were almost 16 because they failed
people then tim
so it was a slightly daunting experience
but you can imagine but things evened
out after that yes i was quite short
in fact i'm still quite short
people got bigger
for a while i was sort of normal size
but that's no longer true there's all
these you know enormous kids who drank a
lot of
milk with vitamins in it
anyway there i was in high school
and
i love my grade 11 teacher that would be
one to the third year of high school
what do you call that
in this day is it something else uh i
guess junior junior year but we've what
do you guys call it fifth form i don't
know if you use british system i have no
idea no that's english what do you guys
call it in canada well we called it
different grades like 9 10 11 12 and in
those days 13 but they've done away with
that yeah we would call it 11 probably i
guess 11th or junior year
junior yeah so my great english teacher
who i put in a book
which is a
peculiar
people go back and they do documentaries
about you right and usually the teacher
says oh yes i could see instantly great
brilliant sean right out of her head and
i can tell she was you know slated for
greatness but she told the truth she
said she showed no particular ability in
my glass which was true i didn't show
any particular ability in her class
and i had no idea then that i was gonna
be a writer
didn't strike me
until the next year
when i had a different english teacher
who i've also put into a story because
she was a
a legend in her own time she
she she took hold of the people in her
class and she
yanked them through the curriculum
no matter what no matter what she got us
through
and her name was miss bessie billings
and she made the immortal comment
because i showed her one of my poems she
said
i don't understand this at all dear so
it must be good
so wonderful i love it that is great
that is great yeah so i started writing
poetry in in grade
12
and uh the story i tell about that is
that i was crossing the football field
and
a pink princess line dress that i had
sewed myself
a work of art tim
you don't know what that is do you
oh i can envision based on some of the
words what it might look like princess
line it had these panels and then it
sort of flared out
anyway it was great loved it i kept the
button
i had a beautiful sort of button on the
front which i still have
oh yes well i'd made a terrible mistake
i'd gone into home economics instead of
the
secretarial sciences which i should have
done
had i known i would have done that and
then i would know how to touch type
which i don't
and it's too late now to so there i was
in my pink princess line dress crossing
the football field and
a poem occurred to me
it wasn't a very good poem but it was a
poem i was very excited about it
and this is how these things start
you write some pretty terrible poetry
that you're very excited about
and luckily there's nobody there to tell
you this is really terrible poetry
and then you go on from there
what did it feel like when this poem
came to you i mean the the lie now you
can tell me how much of this is uh
you know a sort of revisionist history
and storytelling and how much of it is a
reflection of your experience but
quote a large invisible thumb descended
from the sky it's the eureka moment tim
yeah a big thumb came out of the sky
you believe that what else would you
like me to tell you that you will also
believe well i already asked about
astrology so you got me
you can tell me anything yes it was very
interesting to me
and uh i had been trying out these
potential careers like i was going to be
a a painter and then i revised that i
was going to be a fashion designer and
then i revised that and i went into home
economics because in the
textbook it was called guidance
in grade nine you were supposed to
decide what your career was going to be
can you imagine who knows anything when
they're that old oh yeah
yeah not me so the guidance textbook had
had five things that that girls could do
and they did not include astrophysicist
let's see if you can guess what they
were in 1952
i think i can but i'm cheating nurse
secretary school teacher airline
stewardess as they were known and home
economist you've read what i wrote
i know i'm a bad cheater
i am a very good tutor
well you didn't get away with that
oh yeah i know yes that's what was on
offer and being a mercenary child i
looked up what they made
because i did grow up in a family in
which it was expected that you would
support yourself
so the home economists made the most
believe it or not so i went into that
but then i decided no this is not for me
i'm going to be a biologist
i was going to be a botanist because i
was actually quite good at it
and but then along came this writing
and
much to my parents dismay but being the
bite your tongue kind of parents i think
they just hoped it would be a phase
that i would grow out of it
it's been a long phase
okay yeah well they did say the very
practical thing right off the bat they
said well how are you going to support
yourself i said you know i'll get a job
which i did i got lots of jobs and then
my mother said rather caustically
if you're going to be a writer you
better learn to spell
and i said others will do that for me
and you know they have
now we have spell check
[Music]
all good things come to those who wait i
guess
you were right i had to wait a while but
you